نبقى مع سمر بشات وسنرى مصر بعيون المصريه
سمر كيف كانت في 20 22 عصايه شخصي اولا
وعصعيد البلد
ثانيه
صباح الخير يا نادين صباح الخير يا سهام
وكل سنه وانتم طيبين والامه العربيه كلها
بخير يا رب على الصعيد الشخصي الحمد لله
كانت سنه جميله كانت سنه حلوه تحققت فيها
حاجات حلوه وعلى الصعيد العام بقى في مصر
مصر دائما جميله ومليانه بالاحداث الفنيه
والثقافيه مصر بلد حيه لما تمشي في الشارع
الناس كلها عندها حكايات تقولها
واحداث يمكن انا هبتدي انا اخترت المكان
ده هنا احنا هنا في ممشى اهل مصر لان ده
كان اكبر مشروع سياحي اتعمل على كورنيش
النيل همم في القاهره بطول هو يعني
المرحله الاولى اللي تم افتتاحها كانت
1,800 متر بس هيمتد بطول خمسه كيلو مترات
همم ده في مطاعم وفي يخوت ومسرح
وبيستضيف العديد من الفعاليات الثقافيه
والفنيه همم
هننتقل الناحيه الثانيه دي كان من اهم
الاحداث اللي تمت برده
في مصر كان الشهر الماضي همم مؤتمر المناخ
الكوب 20 ايه في شرم الشيخ بحضور اكثر من
60 شخصيه من زعماء ومسؤولين وخبراء وناس
عاديين همم اهم طبعا ال- ال- المحاور كانت
على موضوع المناخ والبيئه وكيف نحافظ على
البيئه واهم تحدي كان بيتكلموا عنه طبعا
زياده الحراره او ارتفاع درجه حراره الارض
وكيف نتعامل مع هذا صاحب المؤتمر ده
الحقيقه طول السنه كان مشاريع كثيره همم
بتدعم ال- ال- ال- البيئه الخضراء وترشيد
المياه وجري لها حاجات متعلقه بالبيئه همم
المناطق الاثريه في مصر شاهدت برده
فعاليات مهمه السنه دي ومختلفه يعني عندنا
مثلا همم لاول مره بيتعمل عرضين للازياء
العالميه في مناطق اثريه منها كان لسه
قريب عرض كريستيانو جار في همم فعند
الاهرامات وكان عرض همم استيفانو ريتشي في
معبد حتشبسوت في الاقصر همم ومن اهم
الاحداث الاثريه ايضا كان السنه دي مرور
100 عام على افتتاح مقبره توت عنخ امون
اللي اكتشفها
البريطاني هاورد كارتر وم- وعلى سعيد
السينمائي اخر حاجه همم اهم حاجه تولى مره
اخرى الفنان حسين فهمي مهرجان القاهره
السينمائي وتم تاجيل مهرجان الجونه لحين
اشعار اخر
وشكرا لكم كل سنه وانتم طيبين كل سنه وانت
طيب ومن قلبي قريب من القاهره سمر رشاد
مراسل صباح العربيه شكرا لك